[Music]
we are at a turning point in our history
as you know there is a growing
disrespect for government it is a crisis
of confidence we can see this crisis in
the growing doubt about the meaning of
our own lives and in the loss of a unity
of purpose for our nation we always
believed that we were part of a great
movement of humanity itself involved in
a search for freedom we've always
believed that the days of our children
would be better than our own but we've
discovered that only things and
consuming things does not satisfy our
longing for meaning wow he is so screwed
it's over for him I thought that was
beautiful stop what thinking that you
know everything that's going on no I do
I just think that you know having your
heart broken is a tremendous way to
learn about the world I see the shapes
I see this sure this is the really hard
part and then it gets better and then it
gets hard again decent you're happy
seriously look wondering if you're happy
it's a great shortcut to just being
depressed love time death now these
three things connect every single human
being on earth we long for love